guys sorry I'm wearing my sunglasses I
have forgot his lids have an operation
no you oh my gosh oh you haven't seen my
eyes oh oh yeah now did you get beat
with two bats or one I got beat with two
bats but apparently the swelling will go
down and that's what happened then it
looks better apparently this is this is
this is permanent it's like you got
stung by more bees than I that's right
this is permanent and this is what I'm
gonna look like so thank you very much
do the podcast without him on but it
might be too distracting so we might
want to keep this on that's not
distracting all right right there's a
hurt low desert doesn't know there's no
pain it doesn't hurt and that weird to
hurt your eyes no your eyes just don't
have a lot of maybe nerve endings and oh
I don't know what it gets better soon
then yep
I think Brennan we have to at least talk
about this you guys if you follow the
news if you're alive if you've been
following this Twitter thing the way we
have you know what's going on with our
friend Chris I'm not you know that when
these situations people in Hollywood
tell you what to say and uh and I said
to Brennan what were you can do is tell
the truth and I'm not gonna sit here I'm
a man and I define myself on how I
respond to these situations in real time
when the pressures really on and so this
is what I'll say
I always knew Chris is a ladies man I
have never and I must say this I have
never seen or heard of him doing
anything illegal ever this is as
shocking to me as I'm watching this
happen I don't know what to think
and I don't know what to say I don't but
I have I'm gonna say it again
I have personally never heard or seen
him do anything illegal that's all I can
say and right now I have to believe that
because he's still a friend and and and
it may be unpopular to say that but I I
don't know what else to say I don't know
what else to do and I'm not going to be
I'm not gonna be some III I just think
it's an impossible situation and I'm I'm
just at a loss I'm at a loss and I'm
praying I'm praying that what I'm
hearing isn't true maybe that's the best
way to put it
and I can't talk it's just you know it's
like it's a weird thing because I said
to Brennan I said it's like um you know
it's it's like watching someone die or
something
and also I just you know what's
important said we haven't spoken to
Chris no and he's never been we never
been on the road with him I you know I
was on the road with him about 14 years
ago once when he was you know just
beginning but I've never been on the
road with him so I don't know I don't
know
I don't know what to think and I don't
know and that's what's so frustrating
it's I'm just sad yeah I'm sad I don't
say Oh anyway yeah sometimes that's the
best thing to say is to say I don't know
what to say and I'm just yeah it's a
it's it's a [ __ ] up thing let you talk
well that's appropriate that's
appropriate right now you can just you
can just pray that that nothing's true
because no matter what the facts are
whatever comes out I'm as shocked as
anyone I'm hurt I'm mad I'm I'm [ __ ]
mad and I'm mad at him okay
okay back back now your lids are the
worst
I thought your lids would be the it's
funny cuz the doctor your lids are the
worst but my concern so my concern
that's right you look you know you look
awful yeah yeah well the doctor goes oh
great perfect great job it'll go down a
little bit we'll take the stitches out
on Monday I was like no I wouldn't have
done this where the stitches that up top
yeah they're up top there along the lid
it's so crazy and then I was I was
picking his brain on how faceless work
and all that they take your face off oh
oh they take your face at the movie they
can do like they there you have velcro
essentially it's like this weird fashion
thing where they could sew don't kid
yourself anybody's ever gotten a face
that has had their face basically taken
off and just though this is a short
operation this is the simplest shortest
operation which is which takes two hours
a lot of times he's standing there
sitting for 10 hours surgeons like that
live sue yeah maybe you're under to a
showers yeah I googled the eye Google's
the whole procedure did you feel
terrible when you woke up you know what
he's just so unhealthy I guess it is cuz
I woke up and I didn't even know where I
was I put my pants on I was talking
apparently apparently they wheeled me
out and I was like this I was like
anesthesia also bad for you dude yeah
well though we're seeing do to your body
they say I'm sure I'm sure you're it's a
nerve blocker it's everything and then
the antibiotics don't make you feel good
so I was like hey let's take these and
it was like does it hurt that bad but
Brett when you believe doesn't hurt it's
just it's just I feel like I'm I feel
like I just pushed my face into a giant
cat they're like balloon like a water
balloon like I feel like I'm putting on
my face is on a warm you like you're
underwater yeah yeah and how long till
they go back to normal because we're in
the fight fan on Saturday I think it'd
be normal by then oh yeah hey your you
have a little thing any knows what there
it is what's the buzz or something I was
like piece of lint was bothering me
thanks dude yeah so uh so there's that
there's that pop we got his lids done
yeah I will never get any plastic
surgery sutures again no it's so nasty
it is that I mean I hope that I don't
you know hopefully you're not all [ __ ]
up but think you think about like the
Kardashians all the procedures they've
got oh my it's just so unhealthy when
you look at what she's been through like
that one girl complete completely
different tightly complete guide
Reformation just complete I mean here
these are breaking bones the [ __ ]
chairs y'all line they put in plan
breaking they extend their hips their
remaining ribs are they root yeah yeah
yes mom that's how they get the that's
not true the other that's other YouTube
you can remove read about that many
times and then you see if that's really
get the V and then they blow out their I
don't believe that I promise
people do it all the time we removal
surgeries to removing one or more ribs
that's [ __ ] you know if celebrities have
been full of gate let me say who's that
blonde the guy or the girl indirect I
think the girl looks like a who's that
girl
that's so weird and then they were those
were they go home girl Zoar so much of
course their corsets well people have
been doing that for centuries women used
to faint when they do it hick see her
name's pixie well she removed it to get
a 14 inch waist
that would make yeah let's not worry
about pixie right now that's to my god
let's talk about the guests we have on
today we had clay Travis on he's one of
my favorite people in media
he's been my MV Peter in this quarantine
he's a guy who's kind of you know I say
mainstream media's the you know an enemy
these days but with clay Travis he's
kind of a no [ __ ] no nonsense he got he
just goes with he's like me he's a
fact-based guy when it comes to sports
his you know his out kick the coverage
show it's a sports show but he's the guy
who you get a lot of information on
corona
he does a positivity post every day on
corona
how he talked about you know the Drew
Brees situation the you know the Mike
Gundy situation everything Kaepernick
situation but he's the guy that I go to
for sports I'm looking forward to it
yeah I am looking forward to what is
he was a lawyer I bet he was a lawyer
huh you know he went on the road with I
think you just opened up for him
looked a little bit like Luke Rockhold
uh well almost but not really yeah a
little bit like Luke Rockhold is like oh
they're our older brother
yeah this smart guy I'm sure I think
you'll dig cuz he's very smart I like I
like his tweets a lot I feel like he's
one of the few people that makes sense
yes so so I would kick the coverage yep
Oh kick the coverage the show that's my
daily listen uh he sent out in the
Cookie Monster suit where go down down
lobster well that's a lobster sometimes
you had a little something strange for
the show you know that's right one of
the Malka guys is dan he's a huge fan he
said that he's joining a that guy Jason
Whitlock now for a new show not a fan
yeah I don't try to cover on the main it
was not just what luck was asked i right
here yeah not family I just never been
divided with his opinions he's always
like I don't know hon mm eh no mames
backcourt MMA is awful than his takin
sports you know I don't dislike him you
just don't I just don't find yeah I just
whatever you know but Clay's brilliant
you know do you think you know more
about football fighting overall fighting
really even after you think so long yeah
why cuz I keep up with I don't miss a
fight you know I kind of you know I know
the code but I mean the technical aspect
of the game and all that right fighting
yeah
hmm yeah scale understand how much do
you think you know about football isn't
could you be an analyst um no that's all
those guys do kind of how all I do is
yeah watch MMA all they do is watch
football so like I couldn't tell you
most of the players on the ramp right of
course is that Tim Tebow right there
yeah Wow doesn't look like him
I know right young tim tebow huh yeah
any clay has I think three kids three
boys
he went to Florida turn all this and
then he also went to ain't Nashville
with Adam Carolla uh-huh because they
did they did some show to get in Jesus
who was that oh well Wow it's
good-looking couple
yeah they are um hey cat can I have some
water since my muffins all go ahead I'm
still in Cobham combo have a razor to
slit my throat yeah I need to replenish
my dehydrated myself 9:53 chilled you
set it up now two more minutes yeah we
just want to just introduce her yeah
cool all right well he's been a guest
I've wanted for a while you know so he's
a guy let's do everyday sports
journalist he's what the a sports
journalist one of smartest people in the
game I just agree with him based on
everything I just like that he goes
through the actual numbers he goes right
the world's on fire but here's the
actual numbers and this is what you guys
should be and he was talks about fair
porn with with a CNN you know Fox News
how all this fear porn is driving the
media yes and he you know and he's like
I'm not a mainstream media guy but
here's the this is what people should be
paying attention to not this over here
so that's why I mess with him so it's
good to have him on the show he's
calling in I wish we'd given studio but
enjoy play Travis Brent um Bob will tell
about that that thing you can wear on
your wrist it matches your sleep your
strain output rocking mind all the damn
time here's the thing again I was on a
stationary bike and it was telling me I
was burning 1,500 calories I'm like
what's weird I've never been thicker and
then I bought a regular bike I'm like
you know I'm gonna start living I'm
gonna get my thick ass on a regular bike
but I was getting my burning as many
cars what am i doing and I would be
tired at night am I getting the right
amount of sleep I was like man hopefully
there's some sort of device who can
track all this by doing my heart rate a
hundred times per second and then whoop
said hold our breast band here you go do
you go and then they did it you wear
this little wristband
it connects through your phone the
device you download the app you get
everything how hard your workout was how
many calories how much sleep you're
getting it
a good day to ride hard as a good day
and workout should you rest recovery
time it does it all
whoop tracks all things sleep from your
sleep cycle stages disturbances your
efficiency and sleeping in Mars how much
sleep you get compared to how much sleep
you need alright and then whoop strap
has a 3.0 five-day battery life on the
go charging so you know you never need
to take it off it's waterproof I swim
with mine on and has a Bluetooth Low
Energy
alright the loop strap 3.0 can connect
to other Bluetooth Low Energy devices so
you can sync your heart rate to
compatible treadmills bikes rowers
whatever you got yeah man I I swear by
this thing I thought it was a good thing
for the Thicke boy by club so many
people I go how far did you ride some
people aren't ebike some people in
regular bike some people are in cruisers
the thin boys aren't cruisers you take
girls on tandem bikes you know you got
people hiking how many calories are you
burning how hard it was your workout
well let's take all the guesswork out of
all that because now there is whoop to
built-in feature with a strain coach all
right let you know exactly what you're
doing man yep
so for you guys whoop is us offering 15%
off with the code fighter at checkout go
to whoop calm enter the code fighter at
checkout save 15% off that's wh ooo P
whoop calm enter fighter at checkout 15%
off sleep better recover faster train
smarter ride harder ride thick optimize
your performance with whoop
we got Clay Travis listen clay has been
my and I told miss off here you've been
my quarantine MVP I listen to you I ride
my bike outs in the podcast when I'm out
there for about two hours so I listen
the whole show and yeah it's just like
you're my go-to then I use I regurgitate
your facts I'm not as smart as you but
I'll regurgitated here Basie I mean I'm
just cheating off you and then I
regurgitated on this show and to the
rest of my friends and like damn he
really knows his stuff
but I'm just using your stuff I
appreciate that look I I said this
before you listen to show you know what
I'm talking about like I tend to
whenever there's a danger or fear
I want to know everything about it
almost like I thought I'm in a fight
with with the media because I feel like
there's so much what I've been calling
fear porn out there convincing everybody
hey you're all gonna die never leave
your home's doesn't matter what it is
and so from the get-go here since this
thing started back in February I've been
tracking it and and I just think the
media as a group has done an awful job
of actually explaining the real danger
for your average person out there and as
a result I think we've made a lot of
really bad decisions that aren't
justified by the day well that's what
surprises me is why in the world
wouldn't somebody who's reasonable look
at the actual data I understand that in
the beginning nobody knew what this was
and they were terrified to the hospitals
would be overrun and there were
projections that said that this thing
could be very deadly for everybody so
you have to give some compassion to
everybody who shut us down even though
it's never happened in our history but
but you know I can understand I I always
called for a targeted quarantine as soon
as we learned that the most vulnerable
people who are older you are saying that
for a while though or jibbety of
quarantine I mean I think you look at
the data from the very beginning and
your guys are raising the right
questions I think we should have had a
targeted quarantine right because around
half of all the deaths in this country
have come out in nursing homes and
nursing home residents represent I think
it's point six percent of the entire
American population if you look at the
data in Pennsylvania more people over a
hundred have died than people under the
age of 45 in the state of Florida big
state not one person under the age of 18
has died for people who are 24 and
younger you are more likely to be struck
by lightning then you are to die of the
corona vine and yet my kids may not be
able to go to school get out there yeah
it's and yet my 12 year old of my 8 year
old may not be able to go to school
because of this and I don't know how to
fight back I what drives me nuts is I
don't feel like I live in a
representative democracy and for
whatever reason I feel like there are
there are powerful elements in the media
that seem to enjoy
Airport this shutdown they they have a
job every day and and the rest of people
and I'm really worried but that the fact
that most of the businesses that will
fail are small businesses which is the
backbone of this country which is the
middle class and what's left then you
know surprise survives this large
corporations so now we have a serf
serfdom we've got a serf class all who
have to get a job at either Walmart
Amazon Apple whatever who've all done
very well with this clay did did you
move to Florida during all this is that
right yeah it's a Florida for the month
of May so I've got a twelve and nine and
a five-year-old three boys myself and so
I obviously they matter more to me than
anything in the world but the fact that
they were out of school makes no sense
from a data perspective right and so I
got so fed up with it you know we were
staying in our house we were trying to
follow the rules but I said as soon as
the states start opening up and I
unfortunately I live in Tennessee which
is a state that started to open up
pretty early in the Nashville area but
then we went down to Florida where the
beaches as soon as the beaches started
to open up I was like screw this I'm
gonna spend may down that hour I'm
fortunate to have a Florida place down
there but I think you you hit on a
really important detail here we have in
this society in our America today
if someone's feelings are hurt by your
facts then you aren't allowed to share
them and you hit on a point I think
everybody's afraid to be fired because
of social media and you go on and say
which I've been saying hey look 7,500
people die every day in the United
States it sucks
I wish we were immortal I wish no one
died but even if the coronavirus is
actually taking the lives that it is
it's still a small proportion of the
number of people that are going to die
every year in this country 2.8 million
people die every year in this country
it's unlikely I think we look at the
2020 data then we're gonna be able to
see much of a difference in overall
death rate in this country that in 2019
or 2018 or 2070 hey you think do you
think do you think that this reaction
would have been different if Donald
Trump wasn't president and you think you
do mmm
so do I I do I think what I think for
better or worse Trump is so polar
rising that whatever he says people tend
to reject it because they don't trust
him or they don't like him do you see
why the people who were saying yeah I
think we're polarized like I think
Hillary would have had the same reaction
to a certain extent the fact that they
ran against each other yeah but I think
if we had a middle-of-the-road president
if we have had a george w bush or if
we'd had a bill clinton somebody that or
maybe even a barack obama first term I
don't think people would have reacted
the same way with such intense
polarization as they have from as a
boogie man knew a lot of things yes and
he makes them respond emotionally and
when you respond emotionally you don't
make logical decisions and I think our
country has just been responding
emotionally instead of using the facts
yeah and that what's surprising to me
too is and you touch a lot on this like
with the NBA coming back and they're
doing this weird circumstance where you
know they're in Florida although I can
ride Splash Mountain the players have to
stay inside so it's like this ride
contradiction but Adam silver has the
same stats that you have access to or
have access to yet they're flying all
these guys down and this is what made me
laugh he goes so the the teams are
quarantined right and he's like well
what are they gonna do with all like you
know everyone has side pieces or they
they have you know their side piece like
whether you do with the quarantine side
pieces then it's a it's something funny
we laugh at but it's a legit concern for
these players like they're like wow I
blocked them for 18 weeks
I think Adam silver is implementing a
plan that might have made sense in the
worst days of April yes by August and
the analogy I'm using first of all it is
funny to think if I were an NBA player a
single NBA player and I was trying to
get my girls in I would be I would be
like Shawshank Redemption I'd be trying
to probe all the different you know like
bubble aspects of security guards who
can I Drive off what can I do to get
some girls into the bubble you're not a
red the green tea tweaks but stay with
me for just a day or two right so I
would start there but when you can ride
every when you can go to Harry Potter
world and when you can go to Legoland
see ya the NBA players are not going to
be allowed to leave a bubble inside of
Disney or
I think they are going to look
ridiculous because are gonna have 30,000
people at NASCAR on July 15 is that
right which football in the 30,000
people yes
30,000 we're at what status 20 percent
that's 20 percent of the population that
ordinarily could get in does it see
250,000 but still on July 15th and
Tennessee 30,000 and you're telling me
in October the NBA is still gonna be
playing without fans present it's crazy
it's crazy plus but I think that they
would wrap the NBA Finals in October so
that's right well I mean but by August
September you're gonna leave these guys
in there when most societies gonna be
back to normal I'll assume by August and
September so it's it's mind blowing
maybe you know this the people that are
driving this narrative politicians
listen very closely to health
professionals and to other other people
they these decisions aren't made by
Gavin Newsom alone for example he's got
a group of people around him that are
telling 15 different things is is this
it was this a situation then is it still
situation I don't know if you know this
where health bureaucrats and I don't
mean that interred spiriting way but
they are health their their their health
officials and we know that people who
are doctors are good people but they're
very cautious they're typically very
very cautious are they the ones who are
calling all the shots here what's going
on like how did this how did this shut
down last this long so first of all I
haven't gotten everything right so let
me say this you'll probably hear oak
plays right when I additionally we had
bad data initially all right so when
China came out with lies and you looked
at the Chinese data and you tried to
combine that with what we were seeing
elsewhere back in February and then you
started to see the outbreak in Italy the
data didn't line up yeah and so I think
the big fall here from the get-go was we
had epidemiologists who were well
intentioned attempting to build models
based on flawed data yeah I'm not a
great mathematician but if you don't
know what the death rate is and you
don't know what the infection rate is
and you don't know what the what any of
those numbers are then when you
put those into your epidemiological
models they spew out all sorts of crazy
results so you had this model out of
England the Imperial College model which
forecast that 2.2 million people would
potentially die in the United States and
so I think you saw that get put on the
desk of all the governors and all the
and all the presidents and everybody
else in the White who are we even at
noon and my god if this happens this is
unlike anything we've ever seen before
but it was a flawed model and we
followed flawed models which were way in
excess of what the reality also well
I've heard that it's not a respiratory
disease I've heard it's actually a blood
disease so that they so we didn't say
yeah there are so many different things
we still don't know well about this
virus that for instance we heard all the
time about how much we needed
ventilators and then later we found out
actually treating people with
ventilators might be a negative in terms
of being able to save them so we have
been trying to learn on the fly and I
think the original sin here was we
bought into what China told us and what
the World Health Organization told us
which allowed us to rely on data that
wasn't real myself included as somebody
who was paying attention to all of this
and we've had to try to catch up to the
perceptions which have not been
necessarily reflected in real data and
we haven't done a good job I think
initially I'm setting this look if we
wanted to shut down for a couple of
weeks back in March because we really
didn't know what we were doing you can
justify that as a safer than sorry
measure but the idea that anybody's
still locked down right now anywhere in
this country and say is insanity and I
find it to it's it's a shame because you
know ESPN these major news networks
especially in sports they can't really
say how to actually feel they have to
paint a certain narrative and go along
with it with the plan you know with ABC
and these other these other companies
like the Fox
you know the main Fox guys on this show
can't you know whatever the show is with
bayless they can't really give numbers
yes PN can't give real numbers so it's
like if you're searching for something
that's how I found you and then I find
an answer
because you know with the drew brees
thing take take the knee you had a hard
stance on where you sure as hell would
been fired from the SPN for that and
then also with uh with a Mike Gundy
situation do you know about this knee so
Mike Gundy is the head coach of Oklahoma
State I think he was there when I played
against them Mike Gundy was a coach and
he went on a fishing trip and you can
fill in the details clay but he went on
a fishing trip and he's where a
conservative Outlet t-shirt is that
right yeah and fishing trip with his
kids and he had on at Oh a yen which is
the one American network now candidly I
don't spend a lot of time watching the
news on television because I think we're
all being sold a bill and goods no
matter what angle you're looking at you
know there's just they're trying to
scare you they're trying to appeal to
your emotions they're not trying to
appeal to your logic okay but whatever
Mike Gundy wants to believe in in his
political opinions he has a right to
wear an OEM t-shirt just like somebody
would have the right to wear a CNN
t-shirt or a fighter in the kid t-shirt
or a now kick t-shirt if you like
somebody and you enjoy the content that
they produce I don't care what you know
political opinions you have and so this
is now turned into a universe I think
all this ties together in all honesty
wrecked we have a world where there is
especially on social media one opinion
that you are allowed to have that's
right if you question that opinion which
is often rooted and emotion not rooted
in facts if you push back and say well
well well you know let's actually look
at the data then you are challenging
someone's feelings and it's like you're
not allowed to push back against
someone's feelings anymore and I think
that's a scary place to be because
feelings aren't rational and the reality
isn't I don't know how you guys feel
well know how I feel yeah I'm not gonna
pretend to walk in your shoes I would
rather look at the larger data and talk
about that because we can all should be
able to agree on a common set of facts
and we can't yeah my money with you
Gundy situation it's like that the
player who said it is might be the best
running back in the nation he's intense
this all-american he's a super stud he's
from Canada
when I saw that you know I thought all
this What did he say when I said well he
was that you know he wanted to protest
his coach and stuff like this where
usually could just take him aside and
talk to him about it but he didn't want
to do that so he goes to social media
when I saw that I went and I don't know
I've never been a GM I've never been an
owner of a football team that would be a
red flag for me against him I would be
worried about if the player does that I
would be very concerned draft him in the
first round if he did that well my
larger my larger thing clay is this is
that what I'm noticing is that the let's
just take the black lives matter
movement let's take these ideas what
what white people in the media are doing
it seems to me or at least people in the
media but primarily it seems to me white
people are are are taking the quote
unquote black opinion and placing it in
a box as if it's a monolith and one of
the things about that I've been doing
for the past three days is watching
intelligent conservative and liberal
black people debate all these issues
yeah and it's fascinating because you
know what you find what a surprise
that in the black community they don't
all agree they aren't all of one mind
they're all over the place like
everybody else because they're
individuals and they're looking at data
too and they're there and they're a lot
smarter than the media gives them credit
for and I'm sorry but when you lump all
these and and white people at these I'm
sorry mostly the white liberal left has
placed black people in a safe space they
put them in a [ __ ] square and they
need to be protected and it's so
condescending it's so outrageous and the
fact of the matter is when I see that
III go you don't have any you actually
don't spend you definitely don't spend
any time in the hood you definitely
don't say any time around black people
and and and it's just it's unbelievable
so to treat black the black opinion as a
monolith which is kind of what Twitter
does because if this kid says something
what happens is the corporations are so
terrified that they move in that
direction because it's safe and then you
get a guy who gets cancelled or censored
yeah what here's what
and I've been on this for a long time so
before I ended up doing what I do now I
went to law school and probably the most
important thing I have found in American
life is our First Amendment rights and I
find that we make the worst decisions as
a country not when we are fighting not
when we're debating ideas do you have an
opinion I have an opinion we talk it out
it's when everybody agrees and I'll give
you two examples I think the two were
decisions were made in the 21st century
we should have never gone in my opinion
we should have never gone to war in Iraq
and hardly anybody was willing to debate
and create we just went to war and we
should have never locked down and stayed
locked down and as long as we have and
both of them were emotional the
emotional response to 9/11 emotional
response to the danger of the Karoo
didn't want to be because you didn't
want to not be a patriot yeah and and
and the lockdown was framed as it's
about saving lives yeah well we're gonna
kill somebody's grandma you don't do
yeah and if you don't go to war with
Iraq you hate America exactly those were
emotional appeal without logical debate
and what's scary is when you have a
consensus that's what happens in
dictatorships in totalitarianism
conflict is good you guys know of course
there's you guys fight it out you're
talking about getting on Twitter to me
if you have a real issue with somebody
don't pull out your phone and especially
if you know them that I decide to tell
everybody about your issue sit down man
to man have a discussion and it's been
my experience white black Asian Hispanic
gay straight whatever you are you come
to a much better resolution face-to-face
than you do firing off at each other on
social media that's right keep keep in
mind that the the Constitution the Bill
of Rights was debated they they they
thought they scream they yell they and
the best idea one you know and the most
important thing is to realize you're not
attached to your ideas put all the ideas
out there and let the best idea win but
right now you get censured for having an
idea for having a different point of
view for having a different point of
waves and also be willing to change your
opinion open-minded you know you give me
new data I'll acknowledge that I was
wrong and I'll adjust my opinion I
talked about that in sports all the time
the team that you get in step 10
is not the team that you're gonna see in
January that's just because you saw a
game and the same thing should happen in
your mind use your mind be flexible to
adjust based on the data and and the
cancel culture thing is guy I am just
it's infuriating to me it's a powerful
don't have an heart can't host the
Oscars does he made a Joe but it was
years ago it works it's a powerful tool
and it works you talk about this all
time clay that canceled culture online
is a small group of people it's one in
50 people are actually on social media
tweeting but this group that gets this
voice and then these corporations pay
attention and then this British doesn't
matter the communist revolution was
started by a very small group of people
in Russia that's right very small is
beautiful here's the analogy I like to
hit is imagine that you were going to a
comedy club and when you're driving up
to that comedy club you see a guy
outside protesting the comedy club with
a poster board sign complaining about
jokes that are gonna be told inside if
you're driving by you think one every
single person knows listening to us
right now and almost everybody in the
country thinks what a loser that dude is
yeah he's protesting outside a comedy
club yet he's willing to get into his
car he's willing to stand in the rain
the snow the sleet the hot sun whatever
it is and he got the poster board and he
got to a location to stand out on the
street corner
yet we ridicule him and say that dudes a
loser if you see the same person online
people are like oh it's so heroic to go
back through some old jokes and be upset
we need the same kind of social
construct online as we have offline and
we don't and that disconnect is blowing
up in many ways many of the things in
our country I think ain't clean in your
opinion do you think MLB figures it out
you think there's a season this year do
you know what's going on there be there
yeah they did say oh we're coming back
for sure the commissioner went yeah
we'll definitely be back and then it
comes out and they're they're so far
apart well cuz this spike in Corona
cases in certain states random it's
different with them it's not Corona them
it's it's money yeah it's all money it's
all money with them right now yeah I do
think they're eventually gonna work it
out you know this thing changes like by
the minute somebody sends out a new
tweet and somebody fires back but I
at some point in July they will be back
they'll come to their senses and
and get back and by the way you just
mentioned oh I was talking about this I
did my research on it everybody's
talking about the second spike in Cal in
Florida in particular a couple of stats
for you that the media is not covering
since and then these are gonna blow your
mind are you ready yes April 15th
all right April 15th to June 15th
hospitalizations for the corona virus
are down 43% in the state of Florida
ventilator use is down 56 percent now
the overall cases are up but the average
age of the person who is getting the
corona virus has gone from 65 years old
to 37 so Wisconsin is younger people are
getting it and they're not having
anywhere near the same issues and one
reason younger people are getting it is
they're going back to work and they're
having to get tested to return to work
yep so if you're young and you get this
thing you're likely to be a hundred
percent fine if you're healthy we want
to keep it out of the nursing homes but
all of the data that I just teach you
the governor released yesterday nobody's
talking about nobody picks it up numbers
are up but they're not that the impact
is down and that's so irresponsible it's
so irresponsible in the media they
should be held accountable for that
because they know better and in my
opinion that's a goddamn lie and in my
opinion they're doing harm we need to
kick start god he isn't everything you
can speak to this clay isn't everybody
scared like the NFL Hollywood everyone's
scared to go back the business in
getting I think it's good to get sued or
backlash from people you know cuz the
majority of people are saying this is
ridiculous how can you do this but I
guarantee you hit Roger Goodell with
those stats he's saying yeah we should
probably hear one you talked about
Donald Trump I think that factors in
people don't want to admit that they
were wrong to shut down so it's unlike
anything else it's like a relationship
that you end up in for way longer than
you wanted to you're like well I've
already been dating for two years why
would I give up now even though you're
like the reality is we should break up
and move
I think we should break up with the shut
down but people are committed to the
idea they won't do it and to I think
it's this fear I think your people are
afraid that they're gonna get canceled
or fired if they come out and they
challenged the prevailing opinion that
is popular in the country right now
which is still hey if you go outside
you're going to be in severe danger then
what best way I know how to do it and
you know this if you listen to the show
I tried to live my life the same advice
I'm giving everybody else need to know
too restaurant you let your kids go back
to their you know their sports leagues
if they'll open but don't stay in your
house get outside exercise make good
decisions in your own life and live as
you would hope that others would as well
yep we live in a time where facts just
don't seem to the the person the loudest
and most savvy person with who controls
the narrative is the winner and it's
really interesting to me we will get you
out of here on this clay hoody when the
MBA resumes who who's your favorite to
win it I mean I'll see the popular
opinions the Lakers with the recovery
and LeBron getting all this rest but I
like Believe It or Not the Clippers and
let me explain why I think you guys know
if you live in LA you spend a lot of
time out there they were gonna be an
underdog with in terms of crowd cuz
everybody's a Lakers fan even in the
Staples Center and now they're playing
with no crowds present at all I think if
you look at the Clippers roster from top
to bottom it's better than the lake or
Oscar I think they will benefit from
playing without fans present at all I
think they are the best team I think
Kawhi and company will end up wasting
the trophy at the end of the year that's
fair I have one more question then I
lied on the last one that will end on
this one
you know how Kyrie saying the NBA
shouldn't come back I find it strange
that the guy thinks the earth is flat is
the representative for these people like
who would follow that guy yeah are you
only come back they should start there
only which is which is even funnier what
the 10th day everything also said not a
lot of us most of us don't make very
much money I mean the NBA players are
the highest-paid athletes in the history
Sports yeah the fact that you would
follow kyrie irving's lead on anything
after you don't believe that the earth
is round
are you optimistic about the future of
this country Ori or can you not ask that
question man I be an insane optimist
with everything because if you look at
the history of America we always get
better right and it's easy for for
people who are pessimists to win weeks
months even years at a time but the
overall trajectory of American life is
better my hope is that we're gonna see a
revolution from reasonable people who
are quiet and start to circle back
around and say we can't allow feelings
to dictate every decision that we make
in this country let's get back to
relying on facts what scares me is we
used to at least start with a common
level of agreement like the facts are
what they are what I keep saying to
everybody is everyone should be entitled
to their own opinion but everyone is not
entitled to their own facts and what
scares me is we have a lot of people who
don't even worry about facts now and you
can't have a reasoned debate if you
don't have a factual basis upon which
that debate is is founded yeah i'm i
personally am optimistic for what it's
worth in that for example like the black
lives matter movement and stuff i think
americans tend to just go crazy it's
like there has to be a period of just
chaos and then what happens is the the
the people who are within the revolution
as I said I've been watching especially
it's relevant because I've been watching
a lot of black intellectuals just black
people have these debates and now now
they get into the real sort of nitty
gritty details of getting better
practically and that's how things move
forward because you can't ignore the
truth forever so so when you hear just
one there's one the media likes to
create one bad guy they take one bad guy
they packs it in the statement the war
on terror or whatever it might be and
they just do that and and you know that
you can sell in a nutshell but at the
end of the day I think it we have to
keep these ideas alive and we have to
realize that all these problems are very
complex multi-layered and we have to
have a free flow exchange of I
Diaz and not get penalized for voicing
an idea that might be a better idea he's
paid close but for reals I think we
swing very often in this country we go
from one extreme I'll give you an
example like we had and this is from a
legal perspective we had situations
where clearly black people were not
treated fairly in this country yes and
then we started to swing all the way to
let's say OJ Simpson to me Oh Jay
Simpson getting off with murder is the
flipside of the Emmett Till situation
you had a completely innocent black man
who was lynched in the south and iMix
Hill that I'm using as an example and
then OJ Simpson basically took that that
atrocity and used it as an argument for
why he wasn't responsible for what he
actually did so we swung from complete
unfairness to complete unfairness on the
other side and the rule the reality is
we want to be right in the middle where
everybody is treated equally regardless
of what their background is their race
their gender and their sexuality
whatever it is their ethnicity their
religion and I think very often in this
country we are hyper reactive and we
swing to both sides I'm an optimist that
we tend to over time move towards
freedom and equality but the way we get
there is not in a straight line if that
makes any sin
you have had a very different
relationship with the police overall or
as have your ebbs have your family and
everybody you know that in the average
white person I believe that
wholeheartedly and I do think that there
is it there is an issue with that
I think there's been great injustice
these riots and this anger is not coming
out of nowhere you just have to be a
student of history and I think that
that's why I think that this is going to
be a change for the better it's gonna be
sloppy it's gonna be messy but all
change is so hopefully hopefully we move
forward as a country I always worry a
clay how was it doing the shows with
Adam Carolla what'd you guys do it was
awesome we did a live show here in
Nashville for his podcast he came into
town and so we had I don't know comedy
clubs there was people there he asked on
stage it was really fun and so he said
he's been going around he went down to
Texas he went in Tennessee
and how about you guys but we do a job
often times when you talk into a mic
with not a lot of people around I love
getting out and actually seeing who's
listening on the other side or who's
reading or whatever else yes so I just I
love those opportunities rare as they
may be particularly in this in this
world that we live in right now where so
many people are cooped up it's just good
to have that human social interaction
agree and be able to kind of see
somebody face-to-face and talk about an
idea funny or or serious or whatever the
case may be three and hopefully the next
time we do the we have you on the show
in person and like I said you've been
them people are this quarantine for me
dude yeah we before we started we were
working together at Fox Sports and one
of our bosses said these guys have got a
killer podcast they are gonna be
superstars in this business and he was
right you guys are killing it happy to
be back on are happy to be on the first
time want to come on again some well I'm
sorry you get a chance to get lost in my
rich Brown is my autumn pound eyes but
that's what happens when you're vain and
you get your eyelids reduced what are we
covered we didn't come back we come back
I'm gonna have great eyes as the doctor
said nobody's gonna notice but you're
gonna look less tired I was like this
cost me 11 grand it look less tired
alright I guess that's what we'll do and
I and I can use the excuse that I can
see now so forgive me for being so
goddamn cool alright clay we love you
man thanks for coming on brother we
really appreciate your busy thanks
brother yeah let's do some current
events how great is clay Travis awesome
on every morning yep okay well a couple
days ago it was revealed that a set of
fossils in South Korea were found and
the animal that they're suspecting the
fossil came from is actually a crocodile
like animal and it shows that it may
have been crocodiles used to walk on two
legs like a Velociraptor I know yeah
that's terrifying
that's terrible magic exists it can
catch you yeah the question is why after
the big meteor hit did animals get less
deadly they had a sea scorpion this
giant sea squirt water yeah that was
like 6 feet tall then a 6 feet long that
would eat any how about the Megalodon
shark was the size of like the Empire
State
not a good time what'd he do wasn't
actually very big but that's very big
now I wonder scary guy yeah and that was
the big evening guess I could make I
liked it you said that but it was very
big how big was the Megalodon shrink
like bigger than a killer whale away big
wasn't hearing a peep out of a [ __ ]
killer whale oh the Megalodon would it's
not hearing people eat a killer whale
that's what I'm saying yeah great whites
one night when they even hear meters I'm
a 3 times longer than the largest
recorded great white 3 times 3 sunshine
shark now that's the size of my Steve oh
that's cool yeah
fifty-nine feast that's fifty nine feet
let's just go 60 60 feet long that'd be
60 feet what's 60 feet long the Empire
State Building apparently well how big
is that those a killer whale how long is
it killer well how long I think that
thing is eating two killer whale oh yeah
saying that but like think about on the
hike if it was like be careful there's
t-rex in this area no one would ever
holiday yes sir
it Dwarfs a killer well it's not hearing
it well bye for now
look male it's 59 feet male is 26 feet
all 59 are you 60 feet yeah that's right
it's twice the size of Shamu it's not
hearing a peep out of the killer whale
like think about what if you're gonna
hike it with the velociraptors have been
seen in the area yeah nobody in the
world see behind that there giant birds
that wake you up huh and can you they'll
pick here with their talons go oh we
have to change the way we live if
there's pterodactyls flying over the
[ __ ] yeah you'd have to have like a
hat with a gun turret and a remote
control I think no one ever leaves a
hath no I'll tell you what we'd have to
do you have to kill all of them yeah
we'd have to kill him yeah you did and
like if you feel like well you know
we've got it we got to preserve these
nails no you can't they're in the air -
it was taking kids out of the [ __ ]
what's a dragon if you like walk and use
- yeah - dragon dragon find out how big
a Velociraptor was please - dragon but
there was even something bigger than the
t-rex oh yeah I mean these dinosaur
books my sons my brains pretty fresh on
dinosaurs yeah they got some serious
[ __ ] velociraptor 633 pounds oh no
I'm talking about
terabyte the Velociraptor a pterodactyl
you could take it now there you go
now there you got oh oh when you spend a
3.5 Fiat dollars away baby
okay so there's smaller birds okay well
problem though you know what movies are
full of [ __ ] I know wait hold on
I feel out of the ways this man was 20
feet oh by the 956 feet that's a big
butt how tall or how much did it well
it's a funny thought if its body is six
feet I'm telling you right now you're
dead it's coming for you wait an eagle
kills things five-hour 50 pounds oh
you're a tush
oh you're dead oh oh you're fun out lion
with wings oh my god mountain lions are
150 pounds oh well sir that's one 550
that's a mountain girl I'm off it's a
mountain yeah my you are sighs that's a
male mountain gorilla with wings
that's the batch the Empire State
Building for the wings yeah it's dead 18
to 18 feet tall we're all [ __ ] oh my
god well guess what kill it you your mom
we'd walk around with a ar-15 and just
sniper now the [ __ ] sky yeah you have
to kill them because they will kill you
there's really nothing we kill these
days unless it as soon as it gets the
taste of a human then we kill it by than
that we really don't if you had
crocodiles that could fly and run Nile
crocodiles they there's no place for
them circle you couldn't have a Nile
crocodile in in the [ __ ] air you like
oh my god that's a crocodile entrie run
Wow things are so much scarier back then
yeah they were you don't think people
would just like kaliesha and try to
constrain it have a pet pterodactyl yeah
like fly on them yeah what else y'all
dinosaurs are cool aren't they coming up
with the woolly mammoth though didn't
they find like some preserved meat
they're taking the cells and rebuilding
a woolly mammoth look you know they look
like elephants with long hair like an
elephant grew its hair out there's like
grunge elephants
yeah I'm verge of resurrection gonna
bring back older vada elephant navona oh
it's a big he's gonna be lonely
it's just Imanol what the [ __ ] dude the
only guy
you do one more yeah you don't have any
friends can you do one more poor little
thing
poor you Ida you think of that all by
itself God look at how big can I go oh
yeah big those tousled tusky tusks are
our scientists on the verge of
resurrecting the woolly mammoth that'd
be cool
Wow you see that I see that it's a
picture those frozen that's a real
picture no all right what else you guys
got alright so last week there were
reports that NYPD officers went to a
Shake Shack in Manhattan and they
quickly found that they were getting
sick after eating their meal and they
found out that there was bleach in their
milkshakes and so they went and there
was an investigation that happened I
caught which department was but um the
NYC BPA pba came out and made a
statement saying that it was intentional
spiking yeah that's why they actually
came out of [ __ ] a couple days ago and
said we spoke too soon it may have been
that whoever was in charge of cleaning
the milkshake machines just didn't clean
it properly and so there were remnants
of bleeding I'm glad to hear that
so it wasn't purpose they wouldn't know
you could do you have cameras you see
somebody go oh I'll take this please
you know Cameras Cameras top floor crime
crime also catches a lot of time huh
okay over ten years ago there was a
writer who had a like antique treasure
chest full of like these old trinkets
and gold pieces
that he hid in the Rocky Mountains
somewhere he's a writer and he wrote the
location of where he hid the treasure in
a form of a poem or something Wow and a
bunch of people came out and tried to
find it because it was estimated over
two million dollars we find Incubus yeah
you just keep it Wow
a lot of people ended up dying while
trying to find the treasure chest and it
wasn't until masti yeah it was until
about two weeks ago somebody came out
and said that they found the treasure
chest
and a lot of people actually sued the
writer for wrongful death suit saying
that oh my husband went to go find the
treasure but we don't think it's real
and you're just doing this to sell books
and so you're responsible for his death
and a lot of people also think that the
treasure was actually never real to
begin with and he's probably doing this
just for publicity but we don't know
because he won't release yeah now they
see the guy who found it doesn't his
name release doesn't want to show the
treasure oh yeah you stole myself he
followed and cheated me to get the chest
I mean what it'd kind of be a boring
movie but I'd watch it or a documentary
yes obsession obsession the Treasure of
the Sierra Madre hmm yep next one step
in the right direction Aunt Jemima
they're going to remove the image cuz it
is actually linked to some sort of
racism back in the day the mammy trope
the minstrel their minstrel shows so
they're back in the days the white
people would dress up usually like
African American and African American
people and they would make fun of you
know they put on black so she was linked
to one of those stores one of those
songs
yeah so they're gonna rebrand it by
changing the logo and they're gonna
change the name to yeah that's pretty
bad yeah also who still uses Aunt Jemima
I mean there's you can get the real
Canadian maple syrup that's the organic
neighbors are so delicious
there was a good there's an article they
[ __ ] the South has weird names like
Jemima there was an article my mother
was reading and Reader's Digest era Co
she's I mean this is so awful I saw
watch because this woman's last name was
hog and her mother named her I mean
parents but I'm a hog they didn't think
about it alright this is another good
step in the right direction the there's
a brilliant Briana's law that passed
that uh bans no-knock warrants in
Louisville and then you also have to
wear body cameras on anyone executing a
search warrant there you go good yeah
that should have been for citizens a
no-knock thing is so crazy to me like I
don't know yeah but yeah step in the
right direction yeah
good cool I do think I want to say
something somebody brought to my
attention about police and police
brutality and all that so I'm another
[ __ ] drink and one of the things that
I think a lot of people especially in
the african-american community are very
frustrated with but in general is that
when there is a shooting when there is
injustice that happens because of this
the blue line cops get each other's
backs the cop police unions are very
powerful and so nobody steps up and rats
on their friends that's how human beings
are that's how dudes are and and and
that's how and yes that's a problem with
loose lips sink ships yes so what you
have to do is figure out a way to to
change that culture yes yeah and I don't
think you get people to change how their
cuz men no matter what they wear they
are out there and war if they're on a
sports team or their friends they get
each other's backs that way but I think
that when there's a wrong being
committed you have to have a you have to
have sort of a situation where you know
where you can't do that you gotta
[ __ ] come forward and say it should
be wrong because you gotta it's wrong
wrong is wrong and you got to speak
about it so you're something like most
of the internal affairs stuff it's cops
talking about other cops they report
other cops something dirty internal
affair that's their job yeah well it's
not not interpret some other some other
things internal affairs the watchdog for
them yeah so they're the ones who have
to be separate and investigate police
wrong you know you know the NBA when
they come back to the season they have a
hotline where players can snitch on
other players I'm not doing the right
protocols Jesus Christ
baby that's great yeah all right so the
last one speaking of NFL I just saw this
like a few minutes ago that's good man
that says [ __ ] they say it's a perfect
fit for the Chargers the way the way
Colin Kaepernick offenses and everything
so how it sounds like you didn't get a
shot is on the workout list whatever
that means what does that mean yeah
workout list so Kevin's on the word so
that means they're gonna work him out we
can put them through drills it's in a
fee you know passes the test that where
they think he's a good fit the price I'm
wow they've got to sign them right which
it becomes LA charges yeah he be be
great here yeah
abraca kaepernick charges jersey
hundred-percent hmm that's pretty much
it boys all right not much good news out
there well we we always do the podcast
at hand eh yeah no matter what's
happening we did the podcast I'm glad we
did the podcast sorry for energy was low
he's great bread the least funniest
podcast you've ever had em though
yeah this is very tough [ __ ] tough
tough tough and as it's more things
happen I'm just I'm a little bit
heartbroken yeah me too
what's the saddest I've been a long time
yeah San Antonio let me Ann Brennan shop
yeah I'm doing with you Bill June 25th
26th 27th I want you to hotel Emma will
be there
come see us it's gonna be fun lol comedy
club gets your ticket to tea fat K calm
and I changed changed my spoken plan so
spoken is now July 30th through August
1st Salt Lake City's July 16th through
the 18th we are doing a the the first
bike big boy bike club will be in Salt
Lake City now so that's July 16th to
18th we will ride on the 18th that's a
Saturday sign up at big boy ride at
gmail.com for that ride to find out info
to join the thick boy bike club there
and then we also ride on August 1st and
spoke in and then Irvine is the end of
August those tickets will go on sale
soon August Nashville and Tampa are on
sale right now DFAC a calm thick boy
calm for the merch crew is that it at
anybody this the fine kid we're out